the agenda is set I'm Brent goth in
Berlin it's time to talk Ukraine's faces
of political contempt can they turn
protest back into peace corruption at
the top China's rotten elite and their
Western enablers and the children our
schools are failing poor marks for
education where it counts most welcome
to the show everyone I've invited three
people today to talk ponder and pry
apart these headlines now how do you
solve the equation good schools plus
healthy students equals a great
education well you can't if you don't do
your homework mariyaan leezar has done
her homework she's an education
education advocate with the NGO Oxfam
mine it's good to have you on the show
today corruption in China it starts and
stops at the top that's what Beijing
likes to believe that's according to go
to and vaca she is an authority on China
with the swp think tank here in Berlin
oh just good to have you on the show
with us and there's a little bit of deja
vu for my next guest she joined me here
a couple of months ago to talk about the
crisis in her home country ukraine I'm
happy to welcome again verenia Solon
inco she was part of the orange
revolution about 10 years ago arena here
you are today an emergency session of
parliament the Prime Minister resigning
is the beginning of peace now finally
coming as if God to say so because after
the resignation of Prime Minister the
president still has to accept the
resignation and afterwards it takes to
Mum this until the new cabinet can be
formed so it might be a sign of
concession but we shouldn't relax I
think until we know whether the position
gains they became a letter not a sign
session what about a sacrificial lamb
right the president he's not going
anywhere right anywhere right and he
might be willing he still has forces to
continue he might be willing still to
fight not to really step back I mean
it's good to have the government he
controls according to the current
constitution the president has a lot of
powers not the Parliament and he has
full control over the government and
over repression repressive institutions
a lot of people are now in detention
those who protested he he has said that
them he would be willing to get rid of
the loss for example against
demonstrating I mean it sounds like the
president is making a lot of concessions
but you're not so convinced are you
let's see what the outcome of this
session is so it's very important of
course to reveal it to cancel those
thoughts yes that's true and also maybe
to adopt some law or decision on free in
those opposition protesters 10 in
detention we know when arena was here
back in December the question was is
Ukraine being pulled apart in a tug of
war between Russia and Europe well it's
become a battle now from within
opposition groups demanding that
President Yanukovych resign and saying
that he's an enemy of his own people
when I'm have Parliament entering in an
emergency session so the question now is
can politicians negotiate a peace before
it's lost completely on the streets
President Viktor Yanukovych offered a
power-sharing deal to senior figures in
the ukrainian opposition Yanukovych
offered the Prime Minister's post to our
sin ESC beauty of the fatherland party
going okay in there the opposition
leaders turned down the archer
acceptance wouldn't
gone down well with their following
protesters have been holding rallies for
weeks in the capital Kiev calling for
the government to step down
the initially peaceful demonstrations
have become angrier several people died
in clashes with riot police in recent
days and the protests are spreading
beyond Kiev closer to Yanukovich's power
base in the east of the country I want
to open this up to everybody these
protests have spread now it's not just a
story in Kiev and should Europe be more
concerned than ever when it looks at
what's happening in Ukraine well I think
there is a concern the question is what
can the EU do what instruments does the
European Union have to have a positive
influence on the situation and I think
that at the moment there are other
suggestions on the table that maybe the
OSCE Switzerland could play a role in
mediating in this conflict while the EU
because it's sort of party of the
conflict should be very careful what it
does so and another question is is this
opposition really a sort of unified
voice is it one camp it looks like it's
more and more split up which probably
then would play into the hands of the
president because if it makes the
opposition of course a week well he's
trying to do that hasn't he because he's
been offering prime the prime minister
position for example he was offering
that to the the opposition but so far
they haven't taken the bait yeah that's
true I think opposition for the past
month as opposition has been quite
united and they played they performed as
one coherent team of course after the
crisis is resolved and they all have
political ambitions it'll all unpack but
at the moment I think it's too early to
talk about that so so far until the
crisis is resolved I think they are
determined to go on as one team we
as a team and Mari on what about the
role of NGOs I mean if something like
Europe cannot help the situation in the
Ukraine NGOs basically they have nothing
to say in this right now do they well
NGOs always have something to say
because they are representing the civil
society and in a healthy society civil
society are a vibrant part to push
certain agenda points and here to also
watch what is going on and to monitor
and to Lee ASB artis could be a very
important role for the non-governmental
side to play but I don't know how how
actively this is also done I mean in
public but I'm sure that there are
things going on where the civil society
is a big part in what about the what
about the condition of civil society in
Ukraine I mean it used to be very good
until the lost past we don't know how
they're going to implement it but until
that surprisingly because the uh no
college freedom limited a lot of
political freedoms society was in a
quite a good shape and was not really
touched and NGOs who played a very
constructive role in the whole protest
movement they have organized ha
logistics behind the stage and they do a
lot of translation of materials from
Ukrainian into English German French
whatever they publish newsletters there
are angels which campaign for people for
the EU to look into bank accounts and
companies which are owned by Ukrainian
businessman who are close to authorities
or soldiers themselves we know for
instance that that Yanukovych son has a
bank account in which a bank and as our
own who is prime minister has a business
in Austria and so on so this is what 680
months exactly in those our bank
accounts that Europe for example could
freeze if they wanted to if they wanted
to exert serious pressure on Ukraine but
that has not happened yes at the first
step one Europe should make is to
investigate the bank accounts and then
if you find there are violations there
is you
active which instructs the banks to do
that fart regulation so if they find
violations they should freeze accounts
here okay let's talk a little bit about
the opposition about these protesters
that we're seeing on this the street
I've had in our programs in the last
couple of days we've had several
interviews with protesters they had
their masks on they were occupying the
Justice Ministry earlier this week but
what struck me in these interviews was
actually help friendly and how nice
these protesters were it didn't fit what
you were looking at how real is that and
you know getting back with NGOs are
these protesters the products of coached
civil society you know organized
resistance if you will yes absolutely if
you go to my down to the states to the
part which is occupied by protesters you
will be amazed how clean it is and the
snow is cleaned very quickly there is no
alcohol there is no garbage it's very
friendly very so I think it's a huge
capital we have experienced at my done
and it's very important to preserve it
afterwards and just just a story the one
of the houses near my done was occupied
by police until basically the day before
tomorrow and the protests has won back
this building and it was an internal
condition with bottles from what girl
and whatever left over there a lot of
garbage they cleaned it was in ours and
it looks perfect now so i think that's
that's very amazing and you're
describing to maybe a opposition a
protesting movement then that maybe has
the stamina to last month's if they have
to maybe a year is that the case yes
many people are determined to stay
actually so this the camp site will be
preserved you can have more people in
the streets on the weekends of course
but people have a lot to lose from going
back to the situation we had before so
they rely determined to change the
country not just to change the
politicians but to change the social
contract between authorities and the
society and now that chain I mean do you
think the opposition any of these
parties that are in the opposition are
they going to accept
shared power with the president or does
he have to resign you you can accept the
shred power the president elections have
come in early next year of course they
will press for early elections but what
is the bottom line they can be no shape
our shared power in the government so
the deal which was proposed a bit
earlier Prime Minister and wise from in
a position with positions like minister
of economy economy is in a very bad
shape or Minister of Interior controls
law enforcement authorities with those
positions staying within the
presidential camps the Prime Minister
cannot really control the situation in
the country so it was trick it was a
trickier and every day people called it
a try and crying hoarse a charge in
horse yeah exactly which which obviously
someone like you know Klitschko he could
see that it was the Trojan horse is
Klitschko is he the hero of Ukraine and
it's pro-european movement yeah I have a
problem talking about heroes I think
this is something you can probably say
in hindsight but it's always dangerous
to make people a hero before you know
you see any exit strategy and any
positive outcome of something like that
so what makes a hero a hero I mean in in
ancient times it was people who fought
very well so far I would agree what you
said I mean if if any of the opposition
accepted this deal it will probably look
like they they are losing their
credibility and but that doesn't make
people a hero but it's a wise movement
not to to step into a trap like that
yeah i would say that every ukrainian
who comes to file is a hero and we have
to bear in mind that at least four
people died and these are young people
who were not correct they were just
peacefully protesting you know right so
these people are heroes and they should
be remembered
what about what we're seeing outside of
of Kiev what about these protests in the
eastern part of the country what's
what's going on there well people are
equally unhappy about Yanukovych and he
threw everywhere all over Ukraine just
in these of the country have been
different economy a structure of economy
than invest in Ukraine but synchrony how
mostly small and medium businesses a lot
of family members work abroad in Italy
Spain as guest workers for instance so
people have no economic independence and
that leads to more political dependence
or independence for expression whereas
in eastern Ukraine you have big
enterprises plans which are controlled
by all the cars that people close to the
President and there you are afraid to
lose the job and of course you are
afraid to speak up and to go out but
nevertheless protest occurred but they
were brutally dispersed in some stitches
in the perugia for instance patna profit
rose it was much worse even than in Kiev
and the problem is done in Kiel when it
is dispersed people go out in more
numbers there it seems to become people
got scared maybe a lot of people are now
in hospitals are in the danger injured
seriously I mean that's one aspect that
we're seeing another are these
right-wing extremists that we've seen
suddenly appear on the scene I think
this they're all is exaggerated I mean a
journalist or we're at my done if you go
to my done behind the barricades you see
people who are who have businesses who
work for companies who are who have
higher education and they prepare
Molotov cocktails you know because
really they're really angry with the
authorities so it's not some right
sector or some extremists but the whole
protest movement has become more
radicalized as a result of violence
because people who were killed some of
them were shot by snipers from the roofs
what is that and nobody investigated
what happened and what is that but what
does that tell you does that tell you
that something may be as happy is that a
home-made threat you don't think it's
coming from from outside from from
Russia for our speculations we cannot
prove that there are a lot of
speculations you
would see some TV Fugit role in Russian
tanks approach in Ukrainian border it
might be somebody tries to create a
panic but it might be true but don't
know really until we have some facts
evidence you cannot say anything because
we've talked about how relatively
peaceful you know this movement has
remained and what about the foreign
influence what are the big headlines
this week has been the US vice president
Joseph Biden calling the Ukrainian
president is is that something that even
matters right now in this is it
something that the world should be doing
well it's very hard to really know what
is what is going on and what influences
what I think it is very important to a
knowledge as it was earlier here that
the opposition is not one opposition so
we have different opinions and we have
to be very careful not to sideline as
the outside of the Ukraine with one
party and then a favor the probably
party which is not really having the
ownership when it comes to representing
the people so I think it is a process we
are in and one is really observing very
carefully what is going on and what
twists will happen very soon and
probably in a week time we will know so
much more and we will also know so much
more who would be the eligible person
representing the Ukrainian society we're
going to move on but you know when you
were here back in December we talked
about the possibility of the Ukraine
actually breaking apart is is that
something that you still think about I
think it can happen in the restaurant
external force which interferes like
Russia otherwise I don't see why it
would happen so if I you know asking you
do you think it's going to happen you
would say no okay good hopefully
hopefully not all right let's move on
now to China its economy is slowing
slight leave sure you've heard the news
but it is still of course in the
breasts laid the rapid growth over the
past decades has pumped up tension
between the haves and the have-nots
China has a new super rich elite and
they have been up to no good that's the
finding of a two-year investigation
based on leaked financial documents from
the British Virgin Islands gross
corruption at the top of communist China
made possible by Western business China
has a new corruption scandal but few
inside the country are hearing about it
a US based group of investigative
journalists says leaked documents show
that relatives of top Chinese leaders
including President Xi Jinping and
former premier wen jiabao are making use
of offshore havens like the British
Virgin Islands to stash their wealth
China's economic boom over the past
decades has created a new class of
millionaires the new allegations suggest
the Communist elite has enriched itself
and hidden the proceeds overseas and
just as officials claim to be taking
action against widespread corruption in
China the government is prosecuting
anti-graft campaigners on Sunday a court
sentence activists shuchi young to four
years in jail his grassroots new
citizens movement has called for
officials to publish their wealth and a
move toward more transparency good let
me ask you is this a a surprise is this
a story to just the West I mean its
corruption anything new to the Chinese
themselves maybe they don't know the
details but I think that it has been
widely known that you know if you are
the sister or the Sun or the
brother-in-law of some high politician
in China you have a battle chance to
become a CEO and get these economic
opportunities without a network of
connections you are nothing in China and
these people are very well connected so
the investigations
that were conducted by Western media but
they were certainly helped by some
Chinese people they reveal that for
example the family of Xi Jinping has
amassed a lot of acids but not cheating
pin or his wife as as themselves and the
same is true for when di Bao in his case
the even the wife is very very rich and
Risa wasn't export for precious stones
so this gave her a position where she
could you know do all sorts of things
not all of this wealth is illegal but
it's probably in a grey zone it's owed
to the connections you have the doors
you can open the influence you can
guarantee over IP and I was that brings
me to something I've been thinking about
researching this story what really is
corruption in China because I'm sure
that with a lot of business transactions
a lot of money goes under the table and
that's considered standard and
acceptable yeah there is all sorts of
corruption and some might be same
illegal and some totally illegal but if
we look at the examples that have come
out for example also that foreign
companies they pay training courses they
invite in order to get a contract they
invite people from this company to make
a training course which means a trip
abroad even to the extent that some
people have complained about training
fatigue so I mean sort things like that
you can say this is illegal it sort of
smoothies the transaction so there are
all sorts of different forms but it's
clear that a lot of corruption is going
on from the lowest level to the to the
highest level what impact can can these
stories have then on corrupt
in China I mean if if names of the
highest political figures are being
thrown out in the Western media is there
the possibility of any momentum being
built that could even you know put top
politicians careers in jeopardy well
there have been careers would have been
very abruptly ended because the
government itself all the new leadership
itself about the first announcement they
made when they came in power Xi Jinping
and Lee kichan was that they will start
a big campaign against corruption this
is not the first time gentlemen the
former president and party secretary in
2002 said that fighting corruption is a
matter of life and death for the party
the problem is that this campaign
against corruption is conducted from
within the party it's organ belonging to
the Communist Party so the problem is
that there are no independent
institutions no control organs no free
media no injuries right judiciary yes
there are NGOs but see what happened I
mean the this one founder of this new
citizen citizenship movement or Citizens
movement God for use in jail and in a
way it shows that the approach to reform
of this new leadership is a top-down
approach it's not a bottom Apple is that
is that the message here if NGO members
who were just basically trying to get
the truth out if they're being punished
for doing that is the message from
Beijing that we want whistleblowers
stopped or is the message we are serious
about finding corruption but it's our
job to fight it both but they don't say
we want to stop whistleblowers because
the leadership of this discipline and
control organ within the party they have
established a website where
whistleblowers can blow the whistle
but they have to use their real name
it's handled in general you have to give
some some people doing that similar
websites by NGOs yeah that were a
private initiative and they were taken
down but there is an official one and
this is too they say to prevent people
from slandering or falsely accusing
officials and in the internet it has
been very common and in these short
messages you post a picture for example
of an official with a golden Rolex so
now you see pictures of officials went
go like this all the time and don't want
to display their wealth anymore but if I
really not what this group want it was
that officials have to make public their
assets something they have to do anyway
but it's not made public it's not known
to the wider public its own just
authority to the party what about the
citizens though I mean of the citizens
they are they are observing this like
with their mobile phones they can take
but they still have to give their name
when they post the picture when they use
the official website they do have to do
that but they can also communicate these
messages with the message services and
in chat rooms with the unite us and stay
anonymous although there is now a new
rule that they have to register with
their real name because what's the
what's the risk in China if if you you
know tell the authorities that someone's
doing something and you know that's
wrong what's the risk of that coming
back and biting you in the face well I
don't know of any cases where this has
come back but probably you these are not
advertised or they don't come up in the
media but some of these cases have led
to the end of the career of officials
like a video that was posted of one
official who had sex with a young girl
and the video was posted it this was one
of the things that was used to smooth a
contract you know to say we are it was
used for blackmail but somebody blew the
whistle on that so it's a very complex
web I think and the question is what is
a sustainable approach if the leadership
really wants to get rid of corruption
and there are some other dimensions in
this campaign we see now for a clean
government against waist against lavish
banquets and stuff like that if you look
at the people who have been accused on
the highest level of corruption some of
them are representatives of big
state-owned enterprises mainly oil
companies and they are usually from a
network from the formal security chief
so this dimension of the fight against
corruption could be a sign that the new
leadership is still trying to establish
its power and to get rid of political
enemies so fighting corruption means
getting rid of your enemies in China
that's one aspect and there is a third
aspect if you take out the CEO of a
state-owned company that have become
very very powerful they're very powerful
vested interests let's assume this
leadership is serious about reforming
the economy maybe even touching these
powerful state-owned enterprises if you
take out the CEO you give a strong
signal to the second in line if the next
time we come and want something from you
you better comply so it's like trying to
kill three birds with one yeah I mean it
sounds like you know a little you know a
little bit from the book of North Korea
in a way we don't like what you're doing
we'll send a strong message we send a
strong message but the message are a bit
yes it can be deadly because if you are
convicted I mean there have been cases
well these officials got the death
sentence so if for example for giving
out licenses for drugs I mean this is a
very powerful position if you can give
licenses for for business right and if
it affects the health well they can get
you in trouble I'm still that I want to
pick up what can NGOs do in a system
like China right now I mean it seems
based on what we're hearing that for
NGOs it's still this big this big gray
area or even a black zone what do you do
well it is difficult and what you have
just explained i think is mainly about
control and not losing control and
transparency and whatever ngos stand for
is probably a danger to the control
factor a government here in china would
like to hold on so ngos can of course
always do a lot of lobby and advocacy
work within the channels which are
allowed talk to people that is one thing
but then of course at the same time make
sure that they are working in the
communes in the communities and to get a
good understanding of the power of
people because only when you have the
power of people together you can really
demand transparency on certain decisions
which are made by the public
stakeholders and that is of course a
very fine line and china always try to
open up or open up a little bit to the
NGO sector to the civil society but then
in the consequence to accepting certain
moves of the civil society they would
shut down and get scared again before we
move on to do with google experiences
from other countries we have like the
color revolutions in the phone that's
true soviet union we have two involved a
very quick question to you children with
the economy in china slowing down does
that increase the risk of more
corruption i don't think that in
races or decreases it everybody in China
or in the Chinese leadership would
acknowledge that certain slowdown of the
economy is needed they want to have a
new growth model they want to be growth
to be based on consumption within China
and not on the investment infrastructure
in order so I well it's a concern
because of unemployment and things like
that but not necessarily I mean the Gini
coefficient the the any quality in
equality in China is already pretty big
people do not mind so much that other
people get rich but if they have the
feeling that they are rich and don't
deserve it and have not worked for it
then they get angry and if they see you
know the son of some function or II
totally and then they get angry courses
they probably should all right nao thanh
to a story that should never be a story
why are nations around the world failing
to invest in the education of their
children the United Nations just
released a report that gives terrible
grades for the global effort to
guaranteed every child a good education
for girls it's even worse if nothing is
done to improve access to good schools
it will be the Year 2070 to before all
the world's poorest young girls can read
and write one of the millennium
development goals set in two thousand
was primary education for all by 2015
UNESCO says that goal will not be met
around the world poor children are
missing out on basic schooling the UN
organization's annual report on
education has repeatedly highlighted the
issue another worrying problem is the
quality of education globally there's a
huge shortage of teachers many are
themselves poorly trained and despite
much improvement one of the greatest
social problems remains the gender gap
in education
activist malala yousufzai highlighted
the issue the Pakistani girl received
world attention for her insistence on
getting an education even after a
Taliban attack what gender disparity in
schooling persists why does it still
persist when we read these numbers from
this report I mean you would think that
it's the year 1700 very true I think
it's a very very sad story to hear that
57 million children are actually
struggling for access to primary
education out of which 32 million our
girls and if you look into that it is
such a multi-faceted reason for it and I
think no reason is good enough as an
explanation for example if you think
that girls are not safe in the school
environment or on the way to school
which is holding them back to attend
school it's very sad when we think of
economic decisions households have to
make and one of the decision would be
not to Syrian their girls to school or
the children's to school this is also a
very sad fact because even though a lot
of government say that schooling is free
there are a lot of hidden expenses
school fees are not there but you have
to still cater for books textbooks
uniforms and parents are asked for
contributions for example if a roof is
collapsing you're right so and also we
shall not forget that in some cultural
settings it's not much appreciated what
a woman actually is doing for a family
and for a communist how much is that
effect I mean economic factors we know
we can spot easily but how can we spot
cultural factors where it simply not
considered as important for a girl to
get an education as a boy that probably
also gets back to education because
people who know how important it is to
have a well educated or educated woman
in a household they know
that the children the whole family is
healthier they know that the woman has
also a value in the market in the
employment market and would be able to
gain income and they would also know
that in the whole governing process of a
country it is very important to have
female voices because they are able to
understand certain circumstances certain
connections in society in a different
way and i would say much better then
sometimes men can yeah i mean also just
look here I mean we are three women and
I think it's not right it's not very
usual also in this format and in this
country to me well I will agree with you
it is not every week that we have three
women sitting at the table that that is
true you need to pick up on gender what
we've talked about with Ukraine and with
China almost everyone we're talking
about in positions of power are men it
that isn't that part of the problem that
as long as men are running governments
women and consequently girls are going
to come up on the short end of education
I think in many households women are the
ones who are making the decision but of
course they have to still convince the
husbands for example how an economic
decision is made and that a certain
token should be reserved for schooling
the girls so I think we also know how
long behavior change is taken in any
society so if we would really get
government's going on certain yeah
valuing and accepting the importance of
the role of women in a society and to
cherish on that and to really bring this
up front in the public that would
definitely have that the right with
Malala for example we shot by the
Taliban and do you think that's going to
make a difference it's not a sustainable
thing to go on one very very sad case I
mean it is also shocking that it takes
such a case to bring up education as
such an education in
written countries to to the public again
it should be an agenda point and it
should be understood also by the
international community that without
having the basics right no development
goal will be reached by far and if we
for example today have still three
countries where you have more than a
million children not attending primary
school and you look where they are you
can't really say oh it's only in Africa
or it's only in Asia I mean it's really
widespread but actually it's all over
the continent I'm talking about is
Nigeria with 5.5 million children is
Ethiopia with more than 1 million and
Pakistan with 3 million so it's really a
global problem and it's our
responsibility to assist solving the
problem to assist the countries on their
way and we do have good examples give me
give me one example we don't have a lot
of time left what's an example though of
a society of a country that has changed
things for the better for example Rhonda
Rhonda was able by political decisions
by government decisions to really
prioritize on education and then they
reformed also the process of how the
money is channeled to the institutions
and together with the civil society they
were able to raise for example the
enrollment rates a lot and to have so
many also girls now at school that it is
a very good example for the whole region
where people are turning to from
governments around to learn lessons
which is also key learning this is
education is it something that it is
naturally an issue for women when we
talk about teachers for example usually
we're talking about women and it's is it
do women have a special responsibility
to make sure that all kids get educated
especially little girls I think women
don't have don't you such a big
responsibility as men in terms of
sustained in the family and that's why
they are ready to accept low paid
positions and that's what we see in the
schools the teachers and schools don't
receive much money
man would go into business or something
else yeah really good about the special
responsibility I'm dealing with the
country where the ratio between boys and
girls is 124 to 100 I mean in China more
boys are born and the reason is very
simple just like in India I don't think
we have a pattern why do we have a
special responsibility everybody has a
responsibility to think about this and
to try to to change it but you can
probably expect more from women because
they should be more aware of this I'm
not so sure that if more women are you
know state leaders this will change
overnight but I think it does make a
difference if more women are in higher
positions I is that the case in Rwanda
for example mariyaan I mean this
improvement did it happen because their
war there were more women actors in
government in NGOs I can't say that from
the data of the number of
parliamentarians for example but I mean
definitely the civil society played a
role and the civil society is definitely
having more female representation than
other bodies but I mean just back to
your question I mean women are raising
the children and we are looking into the
poorest countries and they still bear
the largest responsibility for it so to
understand that usually women do
understand that case still better than
men we're running out of time let me
just ask you that when you look at the
UNESCO report obviously goals are not
going to be met by twenty fifteen or
twenty twenty what's a realistic time
frame to make sure all children have
access to a decent education whatever
time frame I would give is too late so
for example you mentioned 2072 yeah but
it's for both for the poorest girl is
only 86 yeah okay it's terribly and we
have to speed
the process let's wish all children luck
on that thank you very much ladies thank
you very much for being on the show
today keep the conversation going with
us on Twitter and Facebook tell me what
you think of the show today you can tie
me on facebook and you can tweet me at
brent golf TV or you can use hashtag DW
agenda and if you want to watch the show
again go to DW de or watch us on youtube
I'm brink off in Berlin join me next
time when I sect the agenda
you